In previous videos we saw that we can half
Curves using a positional function
In very general terms, the point of x (or x)
A time function multiplied by a vector in a unit
Horizontal direction.
Plus the position of the y-point as a time function multiplied by y = y
Vector unit in vertical direction.
This is an example that explains the idea, if
If you imagine a particle, suppose the variable
G represents the time g = t
This function will describe the position of the particle at any given time g = t
If we want a certain curve to say, that is
It is applied only to a given curve - and the curve we want, that it is t (g) t (g) = r (t)
And it is applicable in the period g greater than g = t
Of a, and less b. A = a, b = b
Thus we described a curve
In two dimensions.
I will draw the curve here
So far we have not done more than a quick review on the last 2 videos
This curve, it may sound something like this
Where g equals t (a)
Thus, when g is equal to (t = b)
Thus, R (a) is this vector r (a)
And ends at this point.
Here is the argument for (g) or time
It is possible to express anything, not just time
But we use time for easy presentation
The higher the g value we move
Or we choose a different point
On the track.
As we saw in the video before the previous.
In the previous video we discussed the
Meaning to take derived from a vector function
We came to this idea - it was not just an idea
In fact, we have shown it to be true.
We have come to a true definition.
That derived g - we'll call it g '- it
You will be a vector.
Derived from a vector function
Again it will be derived.
As we define it - equal to
(G) multiplied by the unit vector in the direction of x + y (g) multiplied by the unit vector in the direction of x x '(t) i + y' (t) j
It can also be written in another way - I will write all the different ways
So that you will not be alienated from your knowledge if you see it in another place -
D (t) / d (g) = d (x) / d (g) ......
D (o) / d (g) is a derivation code
O For time g. It is a standard quantity
The result is this derivative multiplied by the vector of unity in the direction of S.
(D) (d) multiplied by the unit vector in the direction of p
One way of thinking about the concept of derivation
Is that ... when I explain the special rates
With derivatives, the subject seems rather fluid
It is not very difficult
Imagine that you hit both ends of the equation in
(D) = d (t) = d (t) = d (d)
Horizontal orientation.
For the same curve